KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE, ONE WILLIAM
WILLIAMS, DANA PERINO, AND
GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
IT'S A BIG DAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MARKS 500 DAYS
IN OFFICE BY TURNING HIS
COMPLIMENTS.
THE ECONOMY IS BOOMING.
THE NORTH KOREA SUMMIT IS BACK
ON AND THE PRESIDENT HAS REBUILT
THE MILITARY.
BUT THE DARK CLOUD OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL RUSSIA PROBE
CONTINUES TO HANG OVER HIS HEAD.
THIS WEEKEND, SOMEONE LEAKED A
20 PAGE LETTER THE PRESIDENT'S
LEGAL TEAM WROTE BACK IN JANUARY
TO MUELLER'S LAWYERS.
IT ARGUES THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
CANNOT POSSIBLY COMMIT
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE AND THAT
HE HAS A BROAD AUTHORITY TO
PARDON HIMSELF.
THIS MORNING, TRUMP TWEETED HE
HAS THE RIGHT TO PARDON HIMSELF
BUT WOULDN'T BECAUSE HE'S DONE
NOTHING WRONG.
THIS COMES AFTER THE PRESIDENT'S
LAWYER RUDY GIULIANI SAID IN
INTERVIEWS THE PRESIDENT MIGHT
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO PARDON
HIMSELF.
>> DO YOU AND THE PRESIDENTS
ATTORNEYS BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT
HAS THE POWER TO PARDON HIMSELF.
>> HE'S NOT BUT HE PROBABLY
DOES.
HE HAS NO INTENTION OF PARDONING
HIMSELF BUT HE PROBABLY DOES.
IT'S AN INTERESTING
CONSTITUTIONAL ARGUMENT.
CAN THE PRESIDENT PARDON
HIMSELF?
>> Jesse: THE WHITE HOUSE ALSO
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE.
>> THE PRESIDENTS HAD HAVE AN
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO PARDON MYSELF.
WHY DOES HE THINK THAT.
DOES HE AGREE WITH RUDY GIULIANI
THAT A PARDON FOR HIMSELF WOULD
BE UNTHINKABLE AND LEAD TO
IMMEDIATE IMPEACHMENT?
>> THANKFULLY THE PRESIDENT
HASN'T DONE ANYTHING WRONG AND
WOULDN'T NEED A PARDON.
>> DOES THE PRESIDENT BELIEVE HE
IS ABOVE THE LAW?
>> CERTAINLY NOT.
THE PRESIDENT HASN'T DONE
ANYTHING WRONG.
>> Jesse: 500 DAYS, GREG.
FAIR ASSESSMENT, WHETHER YOU
AGREE WITH THE POLICIES ARE NOT.
HE HAS ACCOMPLISHED QUITE A BIT.
>> Greg: I LIKE TO THINK OF IT
AS THE FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF HIS
FIRST 100 DAYS.
A LOT OF STUFF HAS HAPPENED.
I AM NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I AM TALKING ABOUT YOUR LIFE.
THE KEY IS, LIFE WENT ON FOR
EVERYBODY FOR THIS 500 DAYS.
IF A TRUMP CRITIC HAS TO ADMIT
YOUR LIFE EITHER STAYED THE SAME
OR IT GOT MARGINALLY TO
DRAMATICALLY BETTER.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH THE OPTIONS
HERE.
BUT IT DIDN'T IMPLODE.
ACCORDING TO THE PREDICTIONS, BY
NOW WOULD HAVE HAD A CIVIL WAR.
WE WOULD HAVE HAD A NUCLEAR WAR.
WE WOULD HAVE HAD A DEPRESSION,
PERHAPS ASTEROIDS WOULD HAVE
HATE.
WE HAVE HAD PEACEFUL PROSPERITY.
A PEOPLE STEP OUTSIDE THEIR
EMOTIONAL BUBBLE, THEY WILL SEE
IT'S A PRETTY GOOD AGE TO BE IN
RIGHT NOW.
AND YOUR BIGGEST PROBLEM YOU
HAVE IS A PRESIDENT THAT DRIVES
YOU CRAZY BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE
HIS PERSONALITY.
YOU HAVE PROSPERITY, LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT, A STRONG ECONOMY,
NO ISIS, PERHAPS NORTH KOREA
ACTUALLY BECOMING PART OF THE
WORLD.
IMAGINE IF IT WAS BAD NEWS.
IMAGINE HOW THE MEDIA -- THE
MEDIA IS IN A CONSTANT MELTDOWN
WITH GOOD NEWS.
IMAGINE IF THINGS WERE ACTUALLY
BAD.
TO INSTITUTIONALIZE ALL OF THEM.
>> Jesse: JUAN, ARE YOU SICK
OF ALL THE WINNING?
>> Juan: YOU ARE KILLING ME.
HE IS SO POPULAR.
STUNNINGLY POPULAR.
HE'S NOT POPULAR WITH THE
GENERAL POPULACE, BUT HE'S VERY
POPULAR WITH REPUBLICANS.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S KEEPING
HIM AFLOAT.
GREG SAYS EVERYTHING IS JUST
GREAT, SO MUCH ACCOMPLISHED.
BUT I THINK THIS IS OUR
PRESIDENT WHO WORRIES PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT HIM, AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE ACCOMPLISHMENT, HIS
NUMBER ONE ACCOMPLISHMENT I SAW
IN THE WHITE HOUSE RELEASE WAS
OF COURSE REPUBLICANS DON'T EVEN
THINK THEY CAN RUN ON TAX CUTS
IN THE FALL BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
PROVEN TO BE THAT POPULAR.
THE SECOND ONE IS PUTTING A
CONSERVATIVE, NEIL GORSUCH COME
ON THE SUPREME COURT.
YOU WON THAT ONE.
I WOULD GIVE THE CREDIT TO
MITCH MCCONNELL WHO SAVED THAT
SEAT FROM MERRICK GARLAND.
EVEN ON THEIR TAX CUT, THE
DEFICIT CONTINUES TO RISE
INCREDIBLY.
NO PROGRESS ON INFRASTRUCTURE
WHICH WAS A KEY PROMISE.
I COULD GO ON.
BUT I THINK IF YOU WANT, IT
FEELS TO ME LIKE YOU SAY 500
DAYS.
FEELS TO ME LIKE WOW, 500 YEARS.
>> Dana: AND JUAN HAD A WEEK
OFF.
>> Kimberly: SO EXHAUSTED FROM
WINNING.
>> Juan: THE THE THING THATG
>> Juan: THE THE THING THATT
>> Juan: THE THE THING THATS
ME IS THE IMMIGRATION STUFF.
>> Jesse: WE WILL GET TO THAT.
KIMBERLY, THE PARDON SITUATION.
LEGALLY THAT MIGHT'VE BEEN SOME
GAMESMANSHIP.
LOOKS LIKE HE GOT SET UP,
RUDY GIULIANI, ON THE QUESTION I
DIDN'T REALLY KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
HOW DO YOU SEE THE PARDON THING
PLAYING OUT?
>> Kimberly: YOU LOOK AT THE
NUANCE THERE.
IT POSES AN INTERESTING
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTION.
CAN THAT PRESIDENT PARDON
HIMSELF?
THEN HE FOLLOWED UP WITH A TWEET
SAYING HE CAN.
MAYBE HE SPOKE TO SOMEONE AT
SAID YOU'RE SAFE TO GO AHEAD AND
TWEET THAT.
BUT YOU DON'T WANT TO GET TO
THAT POINT, RIGHT, YOU DON'T
WANT TO SUGGEST THAT WOULD BE
NECESSARY.
YOU WOULD SAY OKAY, I HAVE DONE
NOTHING WRONG SO I DON'T EVEN
HAVE TO GET TO THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER OR NOT I CAN PARDON
MYSELF.
BECAUSE THERE WILL BE NOTHING ON
THE MERITS TO SUGGEST ANY KIND
OF CRIMINALITY ON MY PART.
THAT'S THE MESSAGING I WOULD
STICK WITH.
THAT IS WHAT HE BELIEVES THAT HE
KNOWS THE FACTS AND WHAT
TRANSPIRED BETTER THAN ANYBODY
IN TERMS OF WHAT HAS GONE ON AND
THAT'S PROBABLY THE WAY TO STICK
WITH IT.
YOU SAW THE PRESS CORPS WAS
SAYING DOES THE PRESIDENT THINK
HE'S ABOVE THE LAW?
YOU WANT TO SWITCH THE
DISCUSSION, GIVE THEM THE POINTS
TO TALK ABOUT AND DRIVE THE
MESSAGING, TALK ABOUT THE
ECONOMY, TRUMP'S GOLDEN AGE OF
THE ECONOMY IN TERMS OF JOB
NUMBERS AND THINGS AT THAT.
>> Jesse: TO BRING UP THE P
WORD ON PROMPTED.
>> Dana: YOU MEAN PARDON.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT I MEANT,
OBVIOUSLY.
A DAY WHEN EVERYONE WAS TALKING
ABOUT BILL CLINTON AND THE
LEWINSKY THING.
HE DROVE THAT OUT OF THE NEWS
CYCLE AND NOW EVERYONE IS
TALKING ABOUT PARDONS.
>> Dana: THE WHITE HOUSE
BRINGS THIS ON THEMSELVES LITTLE
BIT.
THE PRESIDENT'S TWEETS ARE
DRIVING THE NEW CYCLE.
WHEN HE'S TWEETING ABOUT IT, YOU
CAN BET PEOPLE ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
IF YOU ONLY WANT PEOPLE TO TALK
ABOUT THE GOOD THINGS, TWEET
ONLY ABOUT THE GOOD THINGS.
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
I THINK IT'S INTERESTING THAT
YOU HAVE THIS REPUBLICAN
CONGRESS FOR TWO YEARS.
FIVE MONTHS FROM TOMORROW IS THE
MIDTERM.
RIGHT AFTER THAT IMMEDIATELY YOU
START THE 2020 ELECTION.
I THINK WHAT IS SO INTERESTING
IS THAT DEMOCRATS --
>> Kimberly: HERE WE GO AGAIN.
>> Dana: DEMOCRATS ARE SO
BEFUDDLED AT THIS POINT.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
ALL THESE GOOD NEWS THINGS, IF
ALL OF THESE GOOD NEWS POINT
THAT HAPPENED DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THEY WOULD'VE
TOUTED THEM.
COULD BE THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO USE THIS TIME
TO STEP BACK AND SAID.
POLITICS IS TIMING.
REGROUP.
FILL OUT THE RANKS IT WAS
DEPLETED.
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO TRY TO GET
THROUGH THEM IN TERMS OF IF THEY
COULD FLIP THE HOUSE, WE WILL
SEE.
I THINK IT'S, I GUESS IT'S 50/50
AT THIS POINT.
REPUBLICANS ARE LOOKING
DEMOCRATS HAVE SPENT 500 DAYS
NOT FIGURING OUT HOW THEY LOST
IN 2016 WHICH MEANS THEY ARE
BEHIND IN FIGURING THAT OUT
BECAUSE 2020 IS GOING TO BE HERE
BEFORE YOU KNOW IT.
AND I DON'T SEE HOW THE ROARING
ECONOMY CHANGES.
I DON'T SEE HOW THE FOREIGN
POLICY POSITION CHANGES.
UNLESS THERE IS SOME
CATASTROPHIC EVENT WHICH
HOPEFULLY THERE IS NOT BUT WE
ARE BETTER POSITIONED TO DEAL
WITH.
IN THE MEANTIME, PARTIES CHANGE.
THEY EVOLVE.
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY BUT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
HAS DONE THAT.
THAT IS PRETTY MUCH OVER, AND SO
THE DEMOCRATS ARE THE ONES NOW
THAT ARE IN A POSITION OF
FIGURING OUT, WHO ARE WE AND
WHAT ARE GOING TO BE?
>> Jesse: THEY MIGHT HAVE TO
REINVENT THEMSELVES.
>> Greg: LET'S HOPE SO.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE THE ADVANTAGE
IN THAT THEY ARE OUT OF POWER.
ALL THE TIME IN THE WORLD TO GET
BACK INTO POWER.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO.
THAT'S WHY, YOU KNOW, CARTER WAS
A REACTION TO NIXON.
REAGAN WANTS       WAS A REACTIO
REAGAN WANTS       WAS A REACTI
REAGAN WANTS       WAS A REACTIC
REAGAN WANTS       WAS A REACTIR
REAGAN WANTS       WAS A REACTIE
REAGAN WANTS       WAS A REACTI.
EVERYONE IS A REACTION TO
SOMEBODY ELSE.
THEY SPENT THE LAST THREE YEARS
IN A TANTRUM.
THEY HAVE BLOWN ALL OF THIS
TIME.
I DON'T EVEN THINK THEY HAVE
FOUND ANYONE.
>> Jesse: WHAT WOULD BE THE
REACTION TO DONALD TRUMP.
COULD YOU IMAGINE THE OPPOSITE
OF DONALD TRUMP?
>> Greg: GOOD POINT.
I AM SAYING IT WOULD BE SOMEBODY
INCREDIBLY LEFT-WING.
YOU ALWAYS SEE THE PENDULUM
SHIFT.
THEY MIGHT TRY -- HE IS UNDOING
EVERYTHING OBAMA DID.
THE NEXT ONE IS GOING TO TRY TO
UNDO EVERYTHING TRUMP DID.
>> Jesse: THE OPPOSITE OF
TRUMP IS PROBABLY A FEMALE,
HISPANIC, VERY POLITE LIBRARIAN.
>> Juan: NO, NO.
THE THING IS.
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT.
THE PENDULUM SWINGS.
BUT IF A DEMOCRAT WAS DOING WHAT
TRUMP IS DOING, LET'S SAY THIS
WEEKEND, PUT THIS BUSINESS ABOUT
HE CAN PARDON HIMSELF, CAME OUT
THAT IN THAT LETTER IT WAS
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT HE HAD
DICTATED THIS LETTER ABOUT DON
TRUMP, JR.'S MEETING AT
TRUMP TOWER WITH THIS RUSSIAN
LAWYER.
WE HAD HEARD FROM TRUMP
OFFICIALS THAT WASN'T TRUE,
REPEATEDLY, FROM SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS, JAY SEKULOW, AND
OTHERS.
NOW IT COMES OUT WE WERE LIED TO
AND I THINK IF OBAMA DID
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, JESSE, I
THINK YOU WOULD BE STANDING ON
THIS TABLE, BROTHER.
HE WOULD BE SCREAMING ABOUT
OBAMA.
>> Greg: THAT LIGHT ISN'T EVEN
CLOSE TO BENGHAZI.
BLAME IT ON A MOVIE.
>> Jesse: HE LIED ABOUT A
LETTER, NOT DEAD AMBASSADORS.
>> Juan: WE HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS
CONSOLIDATED AROUND TRUMP.
HE HAS MADE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
INTO THE TRUMP PARTY.
THAT IS WHAT HAS CHANGED IN 500
DAYS.
>> Greg: THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
BECAME THE OBAMA PARTY.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THAT'S
THE CASE.
>> Jesse: AS YOU SAID, THEY
WERE DECIMATED ON THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL.
>> Kimberly: IN TERMS OF THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THE FIRST 500
DAYS, THE ECONOMY.
PEOPLE HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME
GOING AGAINST BILL CLINTON WHEN
THE ECONOMY AND THE NUMBERS WERE
GOOD.
WHAT'S THE ANTITHESIS OF THAT?
UNDO THE ECONOMIC NUMBERS, JOBS?
HEY, ISIS, THEY NEED A CANDIDATE
TO TRY TO BRING SOMETHING
FORWARD.
>> Juan: I THINK IT IS THE
OPPOSITE.
IT'S THE POLAR POLITICAL.
THAT'S BERNIE SANDERS.
>> Kimberly: THEY ALREADY
TRIED THAT.
>> Greg: OLD WHITE GUY.
>> Juan: THE TAX CUT BENEFITED
THE RICH.
BERNIE SANDERS WOULD SAY TAX
CUTS THAT BENEFIT WORKING-CLASS
PEOPLE.
EDUCATION FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
>> Kimberly: YOU ARE LOOKING
AT SOMEONE LIKE A KAMALA HARRIS,
A STRONG CANDIDATE.
>> Juan: A WOMAN.
>> Kimberly: ABSOLUTELY.
IN TERMS OF WHAT SHE'S STANDS
FOR AND SOMEBODY WHO ISN'T THE